[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia heil pen show
powered by
icon plus it's super good to have all of
you guys back again
i will have some really interesting news
announcements for you so i'm actually
hosting a panel discussion um
for icon plus it's called the future of
decentralized finance
and you'll hear from deep by experts
like nicholas martin alex michinski
daiki lee and defy dad as they discuss
the current state of defy
and what we can expect from mass
adoption and whether that will even come
so guys would definitely tune in that
will be on november the 16th
at 12 p.m est live on my twitter so if
you're following me you won't miss it
anyway
also i want to say thank you to my
sponsors blockbuy i use them to earn
up to 8.6 um on my usdc also i'm going
to leave the link in the description i
put it in the tweet i'll put it in
youtube
um because at the moment they're
offering a cool offer whereby depending
on how much you deposit you can actually
earn
i think it's up to 250 so if you click
the link it'll actually tell you how
much you're eligible for so
that would be super cool for you guys so
definitely grab your money
you are um you are owed basically anyway
so this is really exciting i have um a
really cool guest today somebody who is
a new friend
i've recently been on his podcast and i
think we have a lot in common
so it is of course korres how are you
doing
i'm doing great i was just about to
retweet and tell the audience that you
and i are about to be bullish on bitcoin
together for 40 minutes
yeah did you retweet are they gonna
follow
um yeah let's just say about to go live
come hang out
this is gonna be fun yeah i'm looking
forward to it
how are you thank you for joining well i
am great
it's um about the end coming to the end
of the work day and really excited for
this podcast been a while since i've
been on one rather than hosting one
oh okay when were you last on one um
god i can't even remember it's been a
good while so glad to be here
yeah it's great to have you and i'm
actually super excited um because
you're obviously incredibly um you know
well read on everything crypto
everything bitcoin
um of course you are so you know given
everything that's going on with the
markets in the last 24 hours this is
going to be brilliant
so i want everyone just to stick around
because we are going gonna find out what
is going on with bitcoin
um what's causing the pump we're gonna
find it all out so we're gonna talk all
about it but first i do wanna know you
know how did you initially get into
crypto
because we did find out that actually
you and i come from a similar background
from where we're from we grew up i think
we have some like mutual friends when we
were kids
um so how did you get into crypto
well um so getting into crypto actually
unfortunately our mutual background
doesn't come into it
uh it involved one of my friends who
works at
a company that was involved in the
ethereum enterprise alliance
he came to me and he said hey listen
ethereum it's the new internet
and this was at a point where um to
scroll it back a little bit further
i after graduating university um
i got lucky and started a business at
university which did pretty well
and then from that point i was jumping
from business to business looking for
opportunities every time i found
something where i could make money or
um something i'd enjoy i'd do it and
then so he comes that
comes to me at a point where i'm looking
for my next thing and he says listen
this is going to be the new internet i'm
like wow that sounds amazing because
he's
a computer scientist so he was extremely
excited this was at a point
right at the end of 2016. so wow
and then it starts rocketing up and i'm
like okay time to get really into this
and having a mathematics background
trading really appealed to me
so the journey really started with
gambling that transitioned into trading
and eventually i just fell down the
rabbit hole
oh i love that so the rabbit hole we're
gonna get to that because i definitely
want to know about that red bull moment
but i want to talk a little bit more
about you because we're often seeing you
know your technical analysis and things
like that
but you're but like like i said you know
we do have a similar-ish background but
tell me a little bit more about where
you're from
um i think we spoke earlier and you said
actually english isn't your first
language which is insane
because it sounds like it is oh thank
you um well no
actually till i was um five or six years
old i only spoke farsi
um and then when i went to school it was
a bit weird because i had to learn
english
uh all the other kids i couldn't even
communicate with the other kids
so but but it didn't even matter because
we still how old were you
um i can't remember the first age you go
to school at
so i think it was five or six um do
kids start going to school exactly yeah
like five or six in the uk
it's like four or five yeah so if i was
six i'm going to school and i had like
an extra english teacher who was helping
me understand
but honestly it didn't even matter the
other kids just
kids don't care about needing to
communicate with each other it's just
like
you're a person i'm a person we like to
have fun let's have fun together
so yeah um i had to slowly learn english
and um
eventually it got a little bit better
than the farsi and
it's actually why i gravitated towards
maths because the maths lessons were
always easy because that's a universal
language
in english and the speaking that was a
lot more difficult
that makes sense how's your how's your
farsi now can you still remember it
oh yeah i can read and write and speak
fluently so um
definitely put a lot of time parents
made me go to well they made me or
did me a favor of making me go to the
saturday schools where i've learned to
read and write and
definitely fantastic doing those sorts
of things i feel it unlocks
different neural connections or areas of
the brain uh
it really helps you process stuff better
and see the world in or
communication rather in a different
light because you see parallels
and also complete differences between
the way different
languages communicate that's really
interesting you know i think i totally
agree a lot of people say
the most incredible gift you can give
your kids
is to learn is to be bilingual or so on
and so on just to learn multiple
languages for the reason that you said
not just because it's simply convenient
but you know for the reason that you
said so that's really interesting
because english wasn't one of your
strengths you gravitated towards maths
just because numbers are universal so
you started you know going down that
math route is that why
now today you do technical analysis
rather than fundamental analysis or what
you know because
a lot of people get into crypto even
people like myself for example like i do
trade um but not like you do
um and you know technical analysis i
would never say is
my specialty whatsoever um so
why technical analysis well um precisely
for the reasons that you said and to
expand on it a little more
the market is really competitive um
everyone is out there trying to exploit
these inefficiencies
and you need to gravitate towards your
strengths where you think you have an
edge
so naturally when i first got into the
market i'm like where do i have an edge
well i've done a statistics focused
maths degree
so maybe i can translate this price data
better than the majority of other people
can
and that made sense to me so logically
i gravitated towards that rather than
trying to understand the fundamentals of
these companies
where i'm competing less so on the
language perspective but more in the
technical perspective like i'm not a
computer scientist i don't understand
the intricacies of a blockchain company
or a blockchain network
uh at the same level as an expert would
who also happens to have
other fundamental analysis skills so the
technical analysis made more sense to me
and i gravitated towards that
though this year things changed a little
bit a few traders which i really respect
um pushed me towards incorporating more
discretion in my systems
they said chris been in the crypto
markets now consumed in it
for three years at the time now it's
closer to four
and you now have an edge in discretion
because
i've spent so much time in the space
i've spent so much time consistently
talking to people i'm
now fortunate enough to have a network
where i get to speak to some of the most
incredible people in the space as well
and there is a bit of an edge in that
plus there's cautious processing that
comes with being able to see the price
data and the charts again and again and
again
so that's actually what led to me
wanting to start a newsletter get a team
behind me that can
properly process this information and
yeah so
initially super technical focus the
maths led me there
now a lot more towards the fundamental
side uh still
maths focus but i value discretion
hugely
because without getting too far off
track the
topic of ai comes into it and um i don't
mean like
actual super advanced ai i just mean
um high super high
level algorithms um that can develop
upon themselves
they're going to eventually replace
basic systems so
if you're trading i don't know moving
moving average crossovers there are
going to be
out there that can instantly find your
edge and take it out way better than you
can
but if you're incorporating
discretionary elements
then maybe there's a few subconscious um
stuff going on a bunch of variables
which your mind is processing that can't
easily be replicated by ai
even if that is as simple as pure
randomness so
for the longevity reasons it just made
sense okay so were you sort of saying
that you
innovated at a really smart time
at a time whereby you didn't need to
innovate you know the whole idea that
that there came a time whereby you know
back in the day industrial revolution or
whatever machine started replacing
actual men in factories is that sort of
what you're saying
um not that i think it's going to happen
in the near future
but yeah of course i really enjoy
trading and
it's something i'd like to be able to do
as a lifetime career
and i don't want to be putting all my
eggs
in a basket that can be easily replaced
by programs
especially with the way the future's
moving the direction we're moving
towards
it made more sense to focus on bring
those discretionary elements
into the system and again what i mean by
discretionary
is it's not based on technical triggers
it's not like a
this moving average goes here or um this
level breaks with this candle closed and
i enter
it just means my i decide like does this
feel
right to me does this fit into what i've
seen before
yeah i totally understand and actually
that's really interesting that you
mentioned this because i'm doing an
interview tomorrow
with a company who um i guess you could
sort of look at them as like the
futuristic
financial advisors so they as
individuals are not financial advisors
they use ai to give their clients the
advice
um so similar in terms of like
you know it's going down a path whereby
you know your edge could sort of not be
so edgy anymore basically
so i like i like what you've done i
think that's super cool like that's kind
of one of the reasons i guess i brought
you on the show because you know
i can tell you've got that
entrepreneurial mindset you're
innovating and i love it
um but i want to talk to you about this
red pill moment because
you talk about going down that rabbit
hole everybody sort of says you know i
had that moment when i realized
um you know the traditional system was
just collapsing and all this stuff or
whatever so tell me about your red pill
moment
and yeah we'll start with that tell me
about your record moment
sure well i wouldn't pinpoint one
particular moment where i was like oh my
god bitcoin is going to change
everything i need to dedicate my life to
it um it's a lot more subtle
um with business and making a living
in society uh one of the best ways and
consistent ways to do it is make sure
you actually deliver value
so uh say you start up a business um one
of my previous ones was i was
arbitraging
prices of kitchenware goods so i was
bringing kitchenware over
um there was a discrepancy between pound
euro and i had a good connection which
made it really cheap for me to do that
but it was temporary i wasn't really
delivering much value i was just
exploiting one in efficiency and a good
collect
connection and something like that but
i thought if i build a career
and kind of societal contribution
around something which i can truly
believe in which i think can
my logo is build richer lives that's
what i stand behind
and pushing crypto i believe right now
builds richer
lives so it can replace a really
broken financial system it's the best
solution i've seen so far
so i'm not switched on and taking a pill
and i think bitcoin is going to
be the one it's just the best i've seen
right now
it's a strong i hold loosely so if a
better solution comes along or there's a
point where i'm like oh bitcoin
might not be the one that's going to
replace this because we know there's
better
technology out there than bitcoin things
which do the job
on a technical level better but bitcoin
has that brand name
bitcoin has that um no one really knows
who founded it and stuff so
has that about it but say there comes a
point where there's a new coin
with a market cap bigger than bitcoins
and it
has like values to it which we can
put across to say are similar to
bitcoins as well then perhaps
i will also be 50 bitcoin 50 that then
if the data suggests that that is going
to be the one which is going to do what
we want bitcoin to do
which is help take away or crypto and
blockchain as a whole take away a lot of
these inefficiencies from the financial
system
then i'll gravitate towards that so it's
a strong opinion
loosely held i wouldn't say i've taken a
pill and now bitcoin is
absolutely everything okay so two things
there first thing i want to ask you
about um
is you sort of said a broken um
traditional
financial system so um number one i i do
wanna like i do wanna delve into that
and secondly
um if i don't ask you remind me to ask
you um
you mentioned you know if a new coin
comes along then
you know and it's better and it proves
to be better and so on and so on
then you know you'll happily sort of you
know move towards that essentially
so that brings me on to d5 so i will ask
you about d5
and yeah and finance and all that stuff
that happened over the summer um but in
terms
of looking at that broken traditional
system
talk to me about why it's broken because
i often find it's very difficult to sort
of explain this
um i'm in some ways i'm kind of grateful
for everything that's happened this year
just because you know we've seen this
ridiculous printing of money
which has given me a fantastic tool to
sort of say to my friends and my family
and i can sort of say look
they're printing all this money the
money that's sitting in your bank
account is just being devalued as we
speak so
so other than that you know what would
you say is wrong with the system
so we can start with the basic printing
and that is just
it comes in under the form of inflation
which the majority of people don't even
understand what inflation is they don't
understand that if you keep your
cash in a bank account it's going to
devalue it in like 30 years it's going
to be worth half of what it is right now
so that's the one side which you covered
and then there's the other side where
there are these entities in place um
that
that only purpose is to keep track
of records it's to move money from
location a to location
b in a very very inefficient way
and their only purpose is to make money
the purpose isn't to add value to
society and we have a better solution
but these systems are so firmly in place
that it
doesn't seem like they want to go i mean
to take a look at
the new fca regulation in the uk um the
regulation
that you can't do derivatives trading on
crypto
because it's dangerous well wait
why crypto what's the difference between
crypto derivatives trading
and any other assets so and just to jump
in
for those that don't know derivatives
trading just give us like a quick
one-liner
oh sure uh derivatives means you're not
trading the actual
product you are trading something an
instrument which represents
that product and this allows you to take
advantage of things like leverage
um expiry dates if you're doing looking
at futures and a bunch of other
complex stuff but all you need to know
is you're not actually trading the asset
just an instrument which
represents that asset and that was
banned
well yeah it's a blanket ban out of
nowhere um well not out of nowhere it's
actually been in court for like two
years
but yeah you know it's sprung on now and
january 6 that's in place
and the reasoning just doesn't make
sense to me i'd love for someone to be
able to explain it to me because i've
asked the round of people
uh smarter than myself more
knowledgeable in these fundamental
fields remember i am a trader
heart that is my speciality that's the
core of my content
but yeah so that's getting banned but
then
all these other instruments aren't
getting touched or banned let alone
gambling i mean i'm pretty sure gambling
itself hurts more people than
derivatives crypto
trading i have that too someone's just
actually asked a question which i might
put up
on the screen um maybe you can answer
this so it says will i be affected by
this if i trade futures on finance and
i'm from the uk fantastic question
do you know the answers the question um
yes my answer
is speak to a lawyer i'm not about to
give legal advice on a live stream
there you go there you go but yeah i
mean i think
look like i think it's really
interesting when you say um
it's really interesting when you sort of
say it's out of nowhere and i understand
what you mean when you say it's out of
nowhere yes
there has been a two-year court case but
in terms of um
it's reasoning in terms of you know as
if something sort of happened to bitcoin
you know we sort of found out that
bitcoin was a ponzi scheme or something
you know what i mean it's not quite like
that
and overall attack it feels like an
irrational attack on it
i'm sure there's rationale behind it
just not what they're saying it is
100 and for me i think this is a classic
example of being afraid of the unknown
you know where something new comes about
um and sort of seeing how much
i guess momentum is behind it i guess it
it sort of seems like a natural kind of
thing this isn't sort of the first time
that we've seen governments central
authorities
do these kinds of things essentially oh
definitely not
and again like i said definitely not my
area of expertise
this is why i get a team behind me to
help you out with these fundamental
things but um i agree it's but it's it's
a financial revolution isn't it
you're not going to get a financial
revolution without another side fighting
back and trying to stop it
or at least control it um i don't know
answering clark uh something he said
which i really enjoyed in a tweet was
they're not trying to stop it they know
they can't they're just trying to make
sure
you play it by their terms think about
it close down
all these exchanges are getting attacked
um uk is shutting down derivatives
exchanges
hey what if they come back just on their
terms this is how you're allowed to do
it
under our controlled rules and i
absolutely
am regulation i wholeheartedly agree
with you and i think that a clear
example of that was when banks were
now being able to hold your crypto i
mean everyone was so excited over that
but for me it was just like such a weird
sort of like slap in the face
i would just never do that because the
whole idea that we're moving away from
that system and now we're sort of
centralizing something which is supposed
to be decentralized
um it's just another version go on jump
in so i'd say
there are there are some disadvantages
to the complete decentralization because
if it's completely under your control
it's also completely your responsibility
yes agreed which i'm going to get to
yeah yeah yeah go ahead um well yeah get
to it i don't want to disrupt the flow
of what you had planned
well yeah go on actually i was going to
get to it now so speaking of
um people having to be responsible for
their
private keys right to talk out talk
about it at its absolute core
do you you know we talk about this
revolution we talk about banks sort of
not being very good the traditional
system not being very good so
being in this space do you think we then
have a moral obligation do you think we
have a duty to sort of wake people up
and educate them and sort of tell them
what's happening
or do you think some people are just
happier not having to take so much
responsibility
um because it's a lot you know you're
all your finances
on one you know one wallet not one
wallet you can have several wallets
different coins but you know
one key it's a lot do we have a duty to
wake them up
um i think there's two parts to that
that i'm going to approach separately
firstly the
kind of the difficulty and the immense
responsibility that comes with it
now the solution isn't to figure out who
can and cannot handle that
responsibility
it's to make it more user-friendly so
for example i don't know if you've ever
tried to use
uh the hardware wallets we have right
now the ui is
terrible on most i use ledger extremely
yeah ledger you know how difficult that
can be to set up imagine someone who's
not
tech savvy trying to set something like
that up but there are cool
innovative companies like say engrade
for example
that are trying to make the user
interface so easy
that anyone can use it so to make to
bring it to mass adoption to accomplish
that i think the solution is to make it
a no-brainer to make it so easy to use
that anyone can do it now that's not
easy to do
i mean you have to um we need creative
super intelligent people
um not just from the tech side but who
understand people and how they interact
with these things
to make it so everyone can use it and to
answer the second part of your question
whether or not we have a moral
obligation that's quite a difficult
question
i wouldn't say anyone has a moral
obligation to
wake people up because when you say wake
them up it kind of
um i feel and i don't mean any offense
by this that we both
arrogantly assume that we have the right
answer
and i i don't think um
the world is black and white enough to
fully know what the right answer is
but we do have not the obligation
but it's a very positive thing to do in
society
to educate people on it and give them
information in an unbiased way so that's
why i love education that's why i do
education so much on my channel
channel i give the information in an
unbiased way and that's my way of
waking people up but in a non-intrusive
way where i'm kind of
saying this is the way things are
there's no other right answer i'm saying
here's the information now compare it to
the other information you have
and try to come to the right answer from
it
yeah i i totally hear you and i think
it's also because we're so
early we don't really know if bitcoin
technically is the right answer like you
were saying you know if something new
came along
and that was wholeheartedly better in
every single way
and i even mean it to its brand right
and its user experience
and its tps and its you know
scalability everything then you would
move towards it so
i do have a question actually which is
what i was going to ask you earlier what
um before we talk about the actual state
of the markets before we talk about
bitcoin pumping paypal and all that fun
stuff
what is your opinion on um
the coins that we've seen in the last
few months like let's look at yern
finance for example and the way that
sort of just shot up throughout august
yeah tell me about it well um
the d5 craze has been remarkably similar
i don't know were you around in 2017
leah to the ico uh i was literally just
getting into it but i know all about it
so it was
the boom and so on and so on it was
insane you could
get anything you want and the number
goes up you make money on it
and i feel the d5 craze is extremely
similar to that
except on steroids um
very similar themes have come up like
certain words
do really well if anything has anything
to do with polkadot
if anything has the word like yearn dot
something or
similar sounding to something else which
you've done well it starts doing reading
oh my god it's ridiculous you can
actually
trade it like this if you've seen um if
you're around in 2017
you know that you just catch on to these
right themes you make sure the market
sentiment is still the same
and while the market sentiment is
bullish you just write it and you don't
get greedy
you manage your risk and it's like
printing money it is
insane now again easier said than done
because the nuances and the mental
challenge is immense
but the d5 craze right now technology
aside where i can really
add value especially to the listeners is
the market cycle what's happening here
is similar to a bubble and it is a
bubble i mean you've seen these things
go up to absurd values and come back
down but the thing with a bubble is you
never know what the top is
and people use the word bubble as if
it's negative
but bubbles are great you can make
insane amounts of money on a bubble
just don't be stupid don't be greedy and
use tested systems gain experience take
your time
so my thoughts on it are the the
technology is awesome
and it is game changing because some of
the things we have developed
um the oracle systems that are coming
out the way
the blockchains are learning to
communicate with each other it's
really exciting and d5 has immense
potential
but these numbers going up these values
this is just
human irrationalness it's it's um
irrational exuberance that's the word
i'm looking for
it's not anything to do with the actual
value it's
providing it's just the perceived value
which people are doing and that
people are giving to it and they're
getting really excited about it as well
so i think this is a bit of a bubble
very similar to the ico craze
um but d5 itself is really awesome
okay so just really quickly on that
point then d5 itself is really awesome
do you mean long term are we actually
going to get to a point where people are
literally
get you know taking mortgages out on the
blockchain
i mean i think the lending and borrowing
comes out where you can
there are platforms there out there
where you can get serious amounts of
money
um just by signing up to them so d5
lending already exists but um the
question is
can we trust them yet because yeah
that's what i'm saying
it's not it's two issues there's one can
you trust it because you've seen
there's also been more rug pulls than i
think it's been worse than 2017 with
regards to rugbulls and the number of
yeah and the average person when you say
mortgages
yeah people can take mortgages out it's
capabilities are there
but are you going to trust that with
that amount of money
and is the average person going to be
able to navigate the systems i mean even
uni swap is too complicated for
um most people who can most people can
barely use exchanges
let alone uni swap connecting it to
their metamask wallet
like all of that stuff it's the barrier
to entry it comes back down to ui
ui is such a big barrier to entry that
no
right now it's not going to happen but
the technology is there the capabilities
are there and that's why i'm so big on
pushing the adoption that what we should
be doing
is just bringing more talented people
into the space
that's why positivity is so important
leo you love it as well
like spreading that positive energy
around and it's really important because
we want to get more talent into the
space we want to get more incredible
people
into this space so they can innovate
they can make these technologies easier
to use
and integrate them into society you have
such a warm energy i think it's so
important to you know doing exactly what
you said you explain it so well
um abs i think you're such a great guest
honestly you have such a great energy
yeah seriously i think you explain it
really well oh well thank
well there you go well look listen i
think you're explaining really really
well and i think you're totally right
you know
you know you can take that money right
now but um user experience is
just such a problem um you know i've
actually got my
brother and my mum on crypto.com and um
i love the platform i use it
um but but it's a bit of a nightmare
about user experience and blockfire
actually one of my sponsors
and i think they've got a great user
experience um but you know there's
a but there's you know certain platforms
do certain different things things like
uni swap
it's difficult it's not a great ui um
but listen i want to talk about
marketing
yeah go for it i am a big fan of
crypto.com i think the platform yeah
pretty awesome so i personally had a
very pleasant experience with it
um though yeah there are a lot of
platforms and ui issues out there for
sure
yeah no crypto.com i use and i love but
actually
for the average person it's just a
little bit complicated
just a little bit yeah i think so i you
know i was trying to explain it to my
mom and my brother and they get it now
it's not a problem
but like they couldn't understand the
difference between having um an mco card
and then having a fiat wallet
they found that okay holding fiat in two
different places
was a very weird kind of experience for
them
um and i kept having to like understand
the concept of
wait this is different to this and wait
it's usdt
it's not usd yep i was saying to my
brother um you know
true great british pounds and he thought
that i was calling
you know pounds true great british
pounds no that's a stable coin
do you know um like
exactly true great british pounds
literally like being really annoying and
yeah yes exactly being really legal
about it that's what he thought
yeah so it is even some even like the
simplest products which i use and i love
i think there are still
they they still could be easier
basically but look let's talk about
bitcoin um it's been an incredible 24
hours
um what is going on i will get to paypal
it's
not entirely because of paypal just
because i think we were sort of seeing
things on the run up anyway
paypal was obviously a part of that but
talk to me about it what is up with
bitcoin
yeah i'm just getting the chart up in
the corner so yeah look
what are we 12.8 or am i imagining oh my
god 12.9
12.9 almost at 39.
it is now here's an area where i can
give a lot more
specific insight so bitcoin has been
since the dip down the corona dip if you
will
in march uh in a very strong uptrend
and the only time this uptrend paused
was when we got to around
the mid august region now mid august we
had a little bit of a dip
though it was no longer that clear like
up slight low
up again slight low technical analysis
is so easy
when you just zoom out and really simple
perspective
um so what ended up happening in august
was we went up
we had a slight low and then we dipped
through that and we had another low here
then we managed to hold this
and then if you zoom in on the lower
time frames you can see
that uptrend started to build again and
now what we're seeing
is the continuation of that uptrend so
we had a
small uptrend build break resistance at
around
say first major one to break was around
400 and again set that as a support and
follow it very
strongly and now we've set yearly highs
now one thing
in all crypto and this is some alpha
which i always like to share
one of the best ways to make money and
build systems is to bet on crypto trends
over extending that means bet that if a
trend starts
it's going to continue going longer than
you think it's going obviously go back
test and test your systems don't copy
what i'm saying
but that is a really really great way to
build a system
and then when it's ranging and it's not
trending just stay out of the market
right now we are in an uptrend right now
i call this easy mode
just by the dip and worst case you lose
a bit
best case bitcoin does what it usually
does and continues going up
parabolically and what i do is i just
compound that position
until eventually i get invalidated i
stay out the market i try to catch a
trend sometimes on the downtrend it's
quite nice to catch because you get a
violent fall down
but yeah right now i think we're in a
parabolic uptrend period
and if i'm wrong then i lose a bit if
i'm right
it continues and you keep compounding
and compounding and make far more than
you could
lose so the upside severely
outweighs the downside right now and it
has for a little while
since around the um say 11k
area so yeah those are my thoughts on
bitcoin right now
okay so like you said we saw what
happened back in march
um you know due to the whole coronavirus
news incredible
um resilience incredible bounce back so
what do you think is going on in terms
of the halving so do you think that the
harvey has anything
to do with this um a lot of people sort
of said
that around now moving on to q1 or 2021
is when we should start to see
the effects of the halving so has that
got anything to do with it
um give me any piece of news and i'll
kind of show it to you in the thoughts
so when you take
if the price is going up you can find
loads of good news
which can tell you why the price is
going up the price going down you'll
find loads of good news which can tell
you why the price is going down
and we spoke earlier about me using
discretion
and more of a fundamental analysis in my
trading i'm not using any one particular
event
i'm taking the overall sentiment of the
market which is gathered from
twitter media people i speak to
and obviously the price data as well um
having seen similar things before in the
past and my overall feeling
and i take this like aggregate view
combining lots of different factors
i don't isolate one piece of news and
try predict what that's going to do
there are too many variables involved in
trading
and what goes into the price data to try
pinpoint one event and say this one
event is what's going to cause this this
or this
outside of crazy events like corona
where
there's this like global visible panic i
would say that is a black swan event
which does not follow the rules i've set
but with everything else there's just
too many variables involved to try and
narrow it down to that
and it becomes noise unless you try and
group it together
and kind of use it in a system and what
i do is
the discretionary elements of my systems
kind of combine all this news
and help me make those decisions like
will i use this support right now
do i think this resistance is going to
break do i think this up trend will
continue a little more than usual do i
want to up my risk a little bit
all of these slight discretionary
decisions that's how i incorporate it
okay so that leads me on to a really
interesting topic actually
um which is whether bitcoin is a
correlated asset
so there's this whole idea that it's a
non-correlated asset
that's why people love it you know it's
like the world can do what it will do
but bitcoin will do what it does
that's quite funny um so
but but it's not entirely a
non-correlated asset
is it it's an associated asset what do
they say
well so i have the opinion that bitcoin
isn't correlated at all but recently i
had a
conversation with um trader main and
maine has a very strong opinion that
bitcoin is extremely correlated to the
dora
dollar and um the smb so he was telling
me yeah there's a huge correlation i
think bitcoin is just a risk on asset
what i'd like to do is sit down and
literally um
take some like high-level statistical
analysis see exactly what level of
correlation there is
but then again you also run into the
issue of
is it causation or is it correlation
because like with corona
corona took everything down right like
if you look at every chart
everything's going down so you can kind
of make the argument that everything is
correlated from that regard
but then when you think about it it's
the corona causing it it's not that
they're really that
correlated everyone's panicking
everyone's trying to agree
agrees yeah do i think there's
correlation to some degree
yes absolutely but in my own investment
portfolio
i don't treat bitcoin as extra risk on
top of my
stock exposure or my dollar exposure
bitcoin is its own
uncorrelated asset though i definitely
need to do a bit more research
and statistical analysis on how
correlated they are based on the price
data
that would be my experience no solid
this is a decision right now as to
whether i am or not i don't like to take
strong positions
when i don't have data to back it up
good i like that i respect that i think
too many people sort of
take some huge opinions with no evidence
or no sort of whatever we've spoken
about this before so that's cool i
expect that
um in terms of new all-time highs then
you know i just want to get your opinion
you know you don't have to give me a
wild prediction
um you don't even have to give me a date
but i do want to talk about i know
do that too but i do want to talk about
it in general and sort of understand
this
run that we're seeing now is this a is
this a is this the bull run that's going
to take us up to new all-time highs are
we on that trajectory now
i think the i was talking to somebody
today and i think they said like the
entire market cap
sort of that we're seeing right now
resembles what it was before
as the ball run was starting back in
2017 so
the um so the what's the word i'm
looking for i don't know
the reflection the mirror right now the
mirroring is quite symbolic
so um i can definitely give an answer as
to like people want to hear like do you
think we're going to break
20k um it's not a yes or no
think of it as like a meter which kind
of slide you slide across the meter as
to
how likely you think it is that it's
going to happen right now
everything up until the one day suggests
to me that it's very probable
if we get a weekly close above 13k
that becomes more probable if we get the
monthly close that becomes again more
probable so
what i meant by compounding my position
the more probable it gets
the more i add to my position the more
confident i get in my analysis
so right now i think it's likely a
weekly close
would make it would make me say yes if i
had to give a yes or no
will we see new highs i'd say absolutely
yes
how long will it take well it's bitcoin
you could see it in a couple days we
could see it in a couple months or a
couple years
no one knows for sure and it's not that
useful to know
what you want to do is learn how to
position yourself to take advantage of
it
so go study different strategies you can
do that and
that's not just through training either
if you think bitcoin is going to do
really well in the future do what leia's
done start a podcast in the space
that is bitcoin exposure seriously that
is bitcoin exposure go
um if you're a marketer go learn how to
do marketing for a crypto firm
whatever skills you have the crypto
space probably needs it
so you don't have to go try trade
bitcoin there are a million different
ways in which you can get involved and
exposed to it so yes i do think bitcoin
is on an upwards trajectory it's
probable that we're going to see highs
especially if we get a nice weekly close
13k then 14k those are the key levels
above 14k
um my probability doesn't change that
much it's all
fair game over there because we don't
have that much recent price data
but yeah that would be my answer so yeah
i think it's on an uptrend and get
involved in the space guys
i love that and actually that's one of
the main reasons why i love this space
so much because
there's so much opportunity and room for
innovation
um i don't i mean we didn't talk about
this but before i got into space i was
doing the whole traditional media side
of things i found that there was such a
lack of innovation
things felt very stale you know i have
these ideas that i can't really
implement because
the foundation is already built so
you're absolutely right i was about to
say
spoken like a true trader but actually
spoken like a true
entrepreneur really you know this is a
space where everybody has
the opportunity to build something and
add any kind of value that they're able
to offer so you know i think that's
really cool
speaking of i want to quickly chat about
paypal so
what do you think i'll quickly just give
you my thoughts my thoughts are very
much what we said earlier it's kind of
like
if you can't beat them then join them um
and i think paypal sort of have realized
that
but what i will say is i don't think
bitcoin needs paypal i think paypal
needs bitcoin
so um i think paypal is definitely
stronger
than bitcoin right now if you were going
to say like who's the most powerful
i don't like that platform at all the
fees are outrageous it's a
i mean it's convenient to use but it's
painful to use as well
um so they're good for bitcoin at the
end of the day
getting paypal using bitcoin i mean what
yes million users they have 300 million
i could be wrong in those exact figures
but
it is great for bitcoin getting this
this is adoption
this is an easy way think of all those
users they suddenly see bitcoin in the
app
one percent of them are like oh maybe i
should google bitcoin another one
of those they fall down the rabbit hole
then they go tell their friends
so it's great for bitcoin that paypal is
getting involved we absolutely don't
need paypal
in the sense that we don't need the
thing with the audience
we do need the attention we do need the
um
adoption as well because it is a form of
adoption now we have another use case
for bitcoin so
uh it is great for bitcoin in every
single way do i like paypal no
absolutely not
so this is helping paypal and bitcoin
it's kind of like a mutually beneficial
relationship
yeah i totally agree with you i think um
i
i also don't really like paypal i don't
use it i mean correct me if i'm wrong
but paypal generally one of the best
things to do is international bank
transfers right
but it's like hang on i've got crypto
for that actually like
do you know what i mean so i'm just sort
of like oh i don't know i find that kind
of odds
i'm kind of managing just fine without
paypal i think most people
who are encrypted are managing just fine
without paypal but it's
situations where i want to pay someone
in bitcoin and then they asked for
payment in paypal and i'm like will you
take bitcoin
and then i i don't really know so it's
it's in those situations where it is
actually useful i think that was
specifically with i was getting a
personal trainer at one point who was
abroad
and i'm like will you take payment and
crypto it'll be cheaper for you you'll
make more money and he's like i don't
want to learn
nah he should have done he would have
done so well if you paid him in that
oh yeah that money would have definitely
been worth more today than it was back
then
when was back then um this was
a year and a half ago maybe um
damn should have done it what are your
thoughts quickly then on alts and you've
been talking about
link often you know i think we saw a lot
of red across the board i think it was
yesterday or two days ago
um you know bitcoin sort of sucking the
life out of the olds but they seem to be
okay today you you think i've heard you
talk about very positive
about link oh so um i'm a big fan of
link
um also the link community the lick
itself honestly
they're nice aren't they they're all
right they're
nice and no they're passionate let's go
with passionate oh okay when i got
involved in it was i think i said
something negative about link once
and the marines did not like that they
did not like that
well i was just comparing to like i was
just comparing to all the other
communities
because there's a lot of aggressive ones
so i would say linker on the mild
the mild side friends they're they're
our friends
f-r-e-n-s um they're definitely friends
and we love the link community uh
because i mean they're passionate about
the first mover in the oracle space that
is exciting
as a product is actually really exciting
and i get it i get why people are so
passionate about it
what is a little more difficult to
understand
is why they associate random monetary
values
to what it's worth i honestly don't
think the average person has the
capabilities of
determining whether link fundamentally
should be worth ten dollars twenty
dollars or two thousand dollars
so that bit is a little bit irrational
but the
excitement the um
use case of the technology that's
incredible that's awesome now why
i like it oh my god it's a dream to
trade like well i told
those trends stronger than they should
well link is one of the biggest trenders
out there
i mean from four dollars to 20 it was
it was like printing money because like
you just
i assume the uptrend is going to
continue all of my trades are going to
assume that
and you just you you keep winning or as
long as that extends and then
you lose like maybe two trades at the
end and then you just say okay uptrend
might be over and you stop trading and
it's it's that simple so my love for
link comes from
an awesome community i like the
fundamentals behind it i think it's
actually really exciting technology
and also it's a dream to trade
now my final topic that i want to chat
about
um we were going to talk a bit about d5
but i feel like we did cover that
i was going to ask about nfts but we are
tight on time and
i do have a more interesting topic which
i'm really excited to ask you about
so let's talk about the elections so you
and i are both um uk based but who cares
um so we've seen how uh the american
presidential election how you know when
america gets cold the whole world
sneezes
and i don't think americans realize that
so what happens there matters to us
so and okay how do you think this is
going to affect the markets how do you
think this is going to affect the price
of bitcoin i think
um i saw some technical analysis sort of
saying maybe it was goldman sachs i
can't remember who it was
but somebody was sort of saying that if
there's a
blue wave so if the democrats win that
could affect the crypto markets badly
i wondered if you had any thoughts on
this yeah sure i mean
let's start with america knows their
power
they know the effects have they
certainly do they're aware that they are
the global superpower and um
everything they do affects the entire
world now going on to the actual
elections themselves well i don't have
any strong opinion
over what specific effect will happen uh
depending on who wins
but i do have a strong opinion on the
fact that we can expect
volatility leading up to this event so
as we get close to it you expect
volatility maybe pull your risk back a
little bit
maybe pay attention to who's tweeting
what like if someone does some crazy
tweet
by someone we all know trump does some
crazy tweet
um i mean he said negative stuff about
bitcoin before he's pumped the stock
market
i mean this is a funny thought but like
how different is what
trump is doing in the stock market right
now to what the cartoon avatars
do on twitter just and sometimes i do
myself i can be guilty of it as well
just spurs split out bullish stuff about
crypto or bitcoin
trump does the exact same thing and well
we all know the
influences can have an effect on the
market trump's the biggest influencer in
the world
so yeah he has influence on the market
the elections are a high volatility
event we can expect volatility going
into it
but i have no specific thoughts as to
what
what will happen if one person wins or
what will happen if another person wins
yeah i think i think that makes a lot of
sense i think any
time of uncertainty um there will be
um that will be reflected in the markets
you know when we talk about
um it not being a correlated asset i
think times like this will sort of see
that
it's just slightly correlated but in the
long run
no matter whether it's a red or blue win
i definitely just see bitcoin doing
bitcoin
i don't think it's gonna i don't think
it's gonna affect it at all
that's why we're in the space like we
wouldn't be building careers in this
space if we didn't believe bitcoin
is going to win no matter what because
they can see short-term fluctuations
but at the end of the day it's been on
an uptrend since
inception its adoption is only
increasing its use cases are only
increasing
more and more infrastructure is being
built around it society is needing it
more and more
i mean there are times where in iran
specifically
i know bitcoin's price has been worth
like 60k like
60k for bitcoin simply because people
wanted to move out of whatever their
currency is
to get into bitcoin anywhere it's it's a
solution it has
uses and that's only going up so i
expect the price to follow
not literally as in price as this now
and it's going up but the long term
trajectory
with the ups and downs should be upwards
and that's why like a passive
exposure to bitcoin will benefit most
people in my opinion
um but yeah could be wrong definitely
not financial advice
never financial advice but actually just
finally i do want to ask you because you
do have iranian heritage so
what's the situation with bitcoin in
iran do you know um i actually
don't know too much right now okay um
it's
popular i know it's a solution for the
crazy levels of inflation they're seeing
that but it's
not yeah i don't have any specific
thoughts or knowledge
i don't want to give misinformation but
i know it has a purpose
uh just like it does in venezuela and
other countries and
they're experiencing the similar things
yeah it's so interesting and i think i
was i was reading
uh this week uh bitcoin i think was
soaring in turkey just because of
crazy highs um crazy high inflation
rates so
yeah i'd be really interested to see how
it's going in iran um particularly
you know with the kind of government
that they have and so on and so on so
crush i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure having you on
you've given us so much value
lots of knowledge from bitcoin to defy
it's been brilliant i want to thank you
so much do you have any last words for
our guests at all
yeah um thank you leia it's been a
pleasure it's been really enjoyable
especially doing it live i don't think
i've done a live one before
there you go i didn't know that no no no
live ones before i hope the listeners
enjoyed it i hope you gained something
of value
remember do your own research uh there's
no such thing as get rich quick
if you want to succeed in crypto put the
work in uh actually study do your due
diligence if
it sounds too good to be true it
probably is
take care and yeah maybe follow me on
twitter as well
for sure thank you so much and i also
just for the end i'm sorry don't forget
i want to give a quick
shout out to bitcoin jimbo guys you guys
should follow him he does all my channel
art he's super talented if you're
looking for any art done
then go to bitcoin jimbo cool thank you
so much for tuning in thanks for joining
and we'll see you all
next thursday bye bye